[Music]
and breaking tonight we are learning
more about president trump's new
communications platform
called from the desk of donald j trump
the announcement coming
just ahead of facebook's decision
tomorrow about whether to reinstate the
pages
of president trump who was censored by
the platform earlier this year
it's just one of many acts of tech
tyranny
in recent months like how twitter
censored the
new york post story about hunter biden's
laptop
before the election and falsely claimed
it was obtained by hacking and get this
speaking for mr zero experience hunter
biden
apparently he's doubling down on failure
because after his memoir
beautiful things flopped in sales
he sold what ten thousand his first week
hunter says he's writing a sequel hunter
maybe in this book you can explain
how you inked the deal after deal with
ukraine and
oligarchs in kazakhstan and in russia
and
china and shopping sprees maybe you
could tell us where that
uh experience of yours got us or did you
have any qualifications whatsoever
about on any of these issues and did you
lie on your gun
application form about your record on
the issue of substance abuse but of
course
just like we've been telling you the
media mob big tech they are now
acting as an arm of the biden and the
new green deal democratic socialists
and as josh hawley the senator warns in
his new book
if republicans don't take action now
america
will be transformed forever and will
silence our speech
and upend our system of government here
to explain more
missouri senator josh hawley look you've
been through a lot you know
ragnary i know ultimately published your
book it was
actually the same publisher as me and
levin that
originally planned to publish your book
uh they're the ones trying
apparently people in the company trying
to silence uh
vice president pence's book you've heard
about that as well
yeah this is a pattern where you look at
these these corporate
these big woke corporations as simon
schuster's the publisher you're
referring to
who uh commissioned my book and then and
then canceled it and
is under pressure to cancel a lot more
conservatives and the left is not going
to rest until they get every mega
corporation in america
to do their bidding and big tech is the
worst big tech has more power
than any monopoly in our history the
left wants to use that monopoly power to
censor our speech to shut us down to run
our government
we can't let it happen you know cancel
culture is nothing new
to me or to any conservative radio talk
show host
in all 33 years of me being on the radio
i've had to deal with this 25 years
believe it or not here at fox
i've had to deal with this people that
want to shut you down
silence you but now it's even gotten
worse
because as far as i'm concerned
by censoring for example the the new
york post story
as big tech did isn't that an in-kind
donation for joe biden
boy i sure thought so which is one of
the reasons at the time sean i asked the
federal election commission to look into
that very question i said how is it that
these tech companies
seem to be coordinating with the biden
campaign
and and doing them a lot of good by by
arbitrarily
shutting down that story stopping its
circulation you know i think twitter had
the post locked out for what was it like
two weeks from the from their
platform platform their own twitter
account and then in january
we saw these same companies get together
cancel parlor a conservative competitor
throw donald trump off of social media
throw a bunch of other conservatives off
these companies are monopolies sean they
have too much power
the liberals want to have this liberal
big government
big business alliance we need to break
it up i
said for years the only antidote to
liberal media and i i actually said on
this program in 2007 journalism's dead
i was right i was more right than i knew
uh
to me i and then i used to say we've got
to become the media
so conservatives found an outlet talk
radio
uh fox news is now in its 25th year
there was never a fox news before
isn't it really isn't the real antidote
to i know parlor tried it to compete
with twitter maybe that'll work maybe it
won't work i don't know
but to create their own social media
platforms
to bypass these other companies
in other words their own twitter their
own facebook
uh their own youtube their their own
instagram
and i know their efforts to do this but
that to me seems like the only answer
yeah that's you're talking about
competition sean and you're exactly
right what we need is real competition
why do these companies
get by with ignoring 75 million
americans and trying to censor them
it's because they don't have any real
competition and this is what we have
monopoly laws for this is what trust
busting's for
it's to open up space for competition
you know i'm not a big fan of
of trying to regulate these companies at
this that telling what they what they
can and can't say that's what the
democrats want to do what we need to do
is
we need to bust up these trusts and get
real competition in social media
real competition and technology take
away the power that these people have
amassed
by the way they've amassed it using big
government it's because of the big
government handouts that these big tech
companies have gotten so powerful
so we need to stop the gravy train we
need to break up their monopolies and we
need to get
real competition back in the market all
right congrats on your new book senator
josh hawley we appreciate it
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else